this course will prepare you for
JavaScript interview questions focusing
on closures functions and currying
throughout the course you'll delve into
various aspects of JavaScript such as
function declarations Expressions Scopes
and hoisting as well as learning about
advanced concepts like closures and
lexical scope you'll also gain a deeper
understanding of occurring and its
practical applications in JavaScript
roadside coder created this course he
has created many popular courses both on
our Channel and his own channel the
course includes numerous interview style
questions to help you solidify your
understanding and prepare you for your
next JavaScript interview so get ready
to gain the confidence and knowledge
needed to tackle any JavaScript question
on closures functions incurring that
comes your way this is the only video
that you will need to know the most as
JavaScript interview questions on
Concepts like functions closures and
even advanced concepts like carrying we
will discuss different types of
interview questions on hoisting scope
call back arrow function lexical scoping
output based questions partial
application polyfills and much much more
so fasten your seat belt because in the
world of JavaScript the only thing worse
than a syntax error
that breaks your code without even
telling you why or where it happened and
also if you happen to like this video
and if you are interested to watch more
such interview videos you can check out
my channel roadside coder where I've
made a complete playlist on JavaScript
and react.js interview questions which
has helped hundreds of thousands of
developers to crack interviews link to
my channel will be in the description
down below so let's start by basic
questions first which are mostly asked
in entry-level JavaScript interviews so
I've opened vs code over here with HTML
CSS and JavaScript file and the first
question is what is function declaration
so functional declaration is nothing but
when we declare a function like this so
let's say function
and say square and we give this a number
and this returns us anything let's say
so this is a normal function declaration
so this can also be called function
definition or function statement so next
question is what is function expression
so when you store a function inside of a
variable it's called a function
expression so let's say const
Square
and inside of it if I add a function
With No Name this will become an
function expression that's it now an
add-on to this question can be what is
this called so you see this function
doesn't have a name but we are giving
this a name by assigning this to a
variable but this part in itself what is
this called This is called an anonymous
function which is which the function
which has no name and this Anonymous
function can be assigned to a variable
or can be passed as a callback maybe
what is callback you ask we will discuss
that in this video as we go forward now
these function Expressions can also be
called like just like a normal function
is called
like this and or we need to console log
this as well and need to pass a number
let's say 5 and let's see
yep we get 25 over here so a function
declaration function expressions are
kind of same just the differences
function expressions are assigned to a
variable now the next question is what
are first class functions now first of
all let's understand what does this
first class functions mean so in a
language where a function can be treated
like a variable their functions are
called First Class functions in these
cases functions can be passed into
another functions can be used
manipulated and returned from those
functions and basically everything that
a variable can do a function can also do
so this is why we call functions as
first class function in JavaScript so
let me show you an example so let's say
we have the same function function
square and we have another function
which is called display
Square
which takes a function and returns or
let's say just console logs
that function
with a message
which is square is this
so we can call this function display
Square
with this Square function so we can pass
this function inside of this parenthesis
over here and I'm gonna
pass 5 over here let's see
yep so we get this output square is 25
so you understand how powerful functions
are in JavaScript that we can pass them
inside of another function just like a
variable and we can also manipulate and
return them from that function so this
is called First Class function this is a
very important interview question now
the next question is what is iffy now
this is not that much of a frequently
Asked question but you should be aware
of what and if he is so if he means
immediately invoked function Expressions
what do I mean by that let's see so we
have our Square function over here so
when we need to call this Square
function we need to do this square and
then we pass any parameter if you want
and then it is successfully
oops wait let me instead of returning
this let me console log
this over here
yeah so when we call this this is
successfully invoked just like that cool
but what and immediately invoked
function expression does is we don't
need this what we can do we can wrap
this in a parenthesis and we can call it
right away right over here we can pass
uh
argument over here as well and you're
gonna see that our function is still
called
so this is a immediately invoked
function expression now the interviewer
may not ask you exactly what if we is
but they can definitely give you an
output based question based on a fe so
let's check out one output based
question so interviewer can give you a
question like this so what is this let's
understand so this is an iffy and it has
another function inside of this which is
also an iffy so here we are executing
this function by passing this argument
one over here okay we pass the argument
one and then in the inner function we
are passing 2 but we're not using
anywhere but we're just console logging
X and what do you think will be the
output of this question now a lot of
people think that this will give us
undefined because X is not defined in
this scope
but no it will give us the output of 1.
so let's see
yep you see it gave us the output of one
because it's gonna search X in this
inner scope first and when it doesn't
find this X over here it's going to
search in its parent scope and in the
parents scope X exists and this happens
because of closure if you don't know
what closure is don't worry we will have
an entirely separate video where we
discuss some interview questions related
to it and that video will be dropping
next so subscribe if you haven't yet for
now you can understand this the ability
of a function to access variables and
functions that are lexically out of its
scope are called closures so closures
are created whenever a new function is
created because that function has the
reference to its outer scope okay so
let's try and understand more about
function Scopes so I've opened the
official mdn docs for function scope in
JavaScript and we can use their example
to understand how exactly function scope
works so let me copy this up and paste
it over here so you can see that we have
three variables defined and over here
first is num1 num2 and then name
so when we call this multiply function
what's going to happen is it's going to
take num1 and num2 from the global scope
because these are defined in the global
scope and not inside of this function if
there was a copy of these variables
inside of this function it would have
taken that one so let us move to the
other example where we have this case so
we have this get score function over
here where we have num1 and num2 as 2
and 3. but keep in mind we have both of
those variables in our Global scope as
well but these will Shadow the global
scope variable so if you don't know how
where let and const works I've made a
complete video on this topic and I've
explained this shadowing concept as well
in that video so you can click the link
in the description to watch that video
now inside this function when this add
function is run it's gonna take the name
from the global scope and the num1 and
num2 will be taken from the local scope
and it's going to return as the output
roadside coder code 5 so let's see also
I'll provide you the link to this page
in the description below now you see
first returned as 60 which was
multiplication of these two 20 and 30
and the second one returned us 5.
with a global variable as well so this
was a basic example of a function scope
and you can use this example to explain
function scope in your interviews now
let's discuss an output based question
on function scope
so we have this for Loop over here
inside this we have this set timeout
which console logs one and it has a
delay of I into 1000 milliseconds what
do you think the output is going to be
the interviewer can ask what the output
for this code is going to be so now
since we have this lit I over here so
every time this for Loop runs it creates
another block scope for this function so
the first time it's going to be 0 then 1
then 2 then 3 then 4 then 5 but if it
was where over here then where doesn't
have a block scope
then where would have printed five five
five five so let me show you
in this case we get five five five five
five
because we have air over here but if we
change this to let since let has the
block scope it's gonna print 1 0 1 2 3
4. now again to understand this question
properly you need to understand how let
where and const works which I have
explained in my another video which you
can go and watch by clicking the link in
the description so let's move on to
hosting now so you might remember that I
have explained hosting in our valid
const video on how variables are hosted
on top of our code before our code is
executed and how our code is first
initialized and then it's executed so
functions are hosted a bit differently
than a normal variable does now when we
have a function like this and we call it
over here and when we run this you're
gonna see this works absolutely fine but
what will happen if we run this before
the function is declared it still runs
the same it's because functions are
hosted completely so what's what happens
when a variable is hosted so let's say
if we have a variable
x equals 5.
and when we log this
we're going to get the output as 5 but
when we log this before this is even
declared
then obviously we're gonna get the
undefined because of hoisting but in
function that is not the case so let me
show you
if we go to
sources let me put this
right over here
and now when we put a break point over
here
and run this yep inside of our Global
scope you're gonna see we will have a
variable of X which is not defined but
obviously this is hosted so if we go
down you're gonna see we have this
variable hosted as undefined but in
functions in the case of function the
complete function is copied to the scope
so if we go up over here
we're gonna see
we have this function name with complete
function copied to our scope so hosting
Works a little differently in case of
functions we don't have function name as
undefined we have the complete functions
so it doesn't matter if you call the
function before or after declaring it
it's still going to work so this was our
Global scope right inside of a function
we have the function scope and this that
work exactly like Global scope does so
instead of global we have a function
scope so let's say if we have this
variable defined inside this function
over here
and we console log it before it
it's still going to work the same so let
me show you
if I put a console log over here
and refresh
you're going to see inside this local
scope we still have X undefined because
it was hosted on top of this function
so don't worry I'm going to discuss an
output based question which is going to
clear on how interviews can ask you this
type of tricky Concepts and understand
if you have the knowledge for the same
so if you put a debugger over here and
move forward now you're gonna see X has
five because obviously X is defined now
all right pause if you're not yet
following me on Twitter go to
twitter.com underscore Eon or click the
link in the description down below and
hit that follow button right now I'm
waiting for you
I'm still waiting
okay fine let's continue with the video
so we have an output based question over
here on function hosting so I need you
to think about it before answering it
because this is a little tricky one so
we have a where xs21 over here we have a
function expression defined over here
and then we are calling that function
expression so what do you think what is
going to be the value of x over here is
it going to be the local variable or is
it going to be the global variable
a lot of us we will think that obviously
it's going to be local variable right
because this is how this works we will
take the local variable because the
local variable Will Shadow the global
variable okay fine but a lot of people
will think no this is not defined at
this moment this is defined after that
right so this is obviously take the
variable from the global scope
okay that makes sense as well but let's
see what is going to be the output for
this it's going to be undefined why why
is this undefined let's see let's go to
our sources instead of our script.js and
here
let's run this
so we have this Global scope right in
our Global scope we have
X
right over here x as 21 but inside of
our local scope we have X already
present so if you remember in our
wireless const video I explained
hoisting is a two-step process first it
initializes the complete code so it's
gonna initialize the global scope then
it's gonna come to the local scope and
then it's going to initialize the local
scope as well and when it initialize the
local scope it's gonna first host this
variable on top of this scope so in this
scope the x is present and is undefined
right now so we will not take 21 or 20
we will take the X in this current score
because obviously X is not being
initialized at this moment so when I put
a debugger over here and press next now
you're gonna see we have X as 20. so
keep this in mind when we have a
variable present in a scope we will not
go and check the global scope we will
always refer to the current scope so our
next question is params versus arguments
so so this is one topic that confuses a
lot of people which of these is called
params and which of these is called the
argument so when we have a function like
this declared over here and when we call
the function the values that we pass
inside of here are called arguments so
these are
arguments
and when we receive those values inside
of our function this is called params
or parameters
so these are called params and this is
called the argument pretty simple isn't
it now interviewers can ask a confusing
output based question on this topic as
well I'm gonna discuss another bonus
Topic in this video which is spread
versus rest operators so let's say we
have a function called multiply
foreign
we call this like this all right so what
is a spread operator when we let's say
we have an array over here
um let's say 5 comma six
and we want to pass both of these values
to this function we're going to what
we're going to do we're gonna use these
three dots and ARR so it's going to
spread both of these values and pass it
to this function so now you're gonna see
that this runs just like that and it
gives us the output 30 and similarly
when we are passing this to this
function we can also receive it like
this let's say nums
and let's just console log nums for now
you're gonna see that we receive five
comma six so here when we use this
operator this is called spread operator
and here when we use this operator this
is called rest operator so I can
probably do something like num of 0
into nums of one and it's going to give
us the same output yep just like that so
let's discuss a tricky output based
question on this so let's say the
interviewer gave us this code snippet
and asked us what is going to be the
output for this so when we run this
so let's see the output
rest parameter must be the last formal
parameter so you see we combined params
arguments and rest operator Concepts and
we have this question over here so when
we use rest operator or spread operator
it should always be the last one
so just like this so what this will do
is it will take all of these three
values so let me add more values over
here
comma 8 comma 9
so this will take a x a a x y as five
six three and the numbers will take the
remaining value so that's why we add it
at the last of our list of parameters so
that it takes all of the remaining
arguments so if I say numbers
and now you're going to see it runs
properly up six three and seven eight
nine so six three and seven eight nine
which were the remaining arguments great
so I know this was a little tricky one
if you're not aware of rest operator or
spread operators but it's fine you're
gonna get good with time as you use this
rest operator spread operators in your
projects and in your apps so the next
question is what is a callback function
so actually we have already seen this in
our first class function topic so let me
go to the official Mozilla documentation
and here in the definition you can see a
callback function is a function passed
into another function as an argument
which is then invoked inside the outer
function to complete some kind of
routine or action so as I mentioned
functions are first class function in
JavaScript so when we have a function
like this and a function like this we
are passing this greeting inside of this
function and it's taking this greeting
callback so this greeting is what a
callback function is so as the name
suggests the function says that you can
call me back whenever you like so the
function is sending itself to this
function and it is calling it inside of
this other function so this is exactly
what a callback function is all about
now interviewer can ask you question
like can you give us an example on what
a callback function is so you can give
that example and also you can give the
example inside the JavaScript predefined
functions which are something like set
timeout map filter reduce so let me give
you an example something like when we
use event listeners so
document
add event listener this takes two things
it takes the event which let's say click
event and then it takes a callback over
here just like that so this is what a
callback is when we are passing a
function inside of another function and
then this function is manipulated inside
of this one
so it can be event listeners it can be
function like map filter reduce or set
timeout so if you don't know I've made
up actually made another video on map
filter reduce as well which is our
previous video you can click the link in
the description to understand these
topics thoroughly now last but not the
least we have Arrow functions now what
are Arrow functions so Arrow functions
were introduced in es6 version of
JavaScript and they were kind of like
similar to a normal function but in some
ways they work differently so let me
show you if you see a normal function
its syntax looks something like this so
we have a function called add over here
in which we takes two parameters and
returned some value
so what are we going to do if we need to
convert this function into an arrow
function so we just need to get rid of
this function keyword and we need to add
an arrow over here and that's it we're
done that is what an arrow function is
it has a bit more clean syntax and
actually we can get rid of these curly
braces as well since this is returning
only one line and we can get rid of this
return as well over here so yep you can
see this syntax looks much cleaner than
the previous syntax but when we use the
curly braces we do need to use return or
I mean according to our requirements so
let's discuss some of the differences
between Arrow function and a normal
function because this is a really
important interview question so the
first one is what we have already
discussed is the syntax so the syntax of
a normal function looks something like
this with the function keyword but the
syntax of an arrow function looks
something like this with this Arrow
operator okay now the second difference
the implicit returned keyword so I've
already showed you that in a normal
function we can use return like this but
in an arrow function we can do something
like we can get rid of return function
if this is a one-liner
and we can write something like this
third point would be is the arguments
keyword so if let me show you so if we
have a function inside of this width
let's say we have we don't have any
parameters and we just console log
arguments over here now if I call this
function
with 1 comma 2 comma 3 whatever so then
we're gonna see
oops A square has already been declared
let me use this names okay now you're
gonna see we get this arguments with all
of these arguments so we didn't even
pass the parameter over here but we got
all of the arguments just like this
but can we do this in Arrow function
let's see
function keyword and make it a
Arrow function now let's see you're
gonna get the output arguments is not
defined so you cannot have the arguments
keyword inside of an arrow function
okay
let's comment this out as well now the
fourth point will be the this keyword
how does this keyword perform with
normal function and the arrow function
now obviously if you don't know what
this keyword is don't worry I'll create
another separate video on this topic so
let me have a question over here which
can be considered as an output based
question so interviewer can give you
something like this so inside this
object we have a username
and we have two functions over here
first function is an arrow function and
second function is a regular function so
let's see how both of these performed I
have called both of these functions over
here and let's see the output so the
first Arrow function gives us subscribe
to and undefined but the second regular
function gives us subscribe to roadside
coder it's because this here is pointing
to this object but this inside of this
function is pointing to the global
object so I know if you don't have the
proper knowledge of this keyword it's
hard to understand right now but don't
worry I will come up with a separate
video for this keyword so yeah these
were the major four differences between
Arrow function and a regular function
now there can be more differences as
well like how the Constructor is defined
inside of both of these but that would
be a little Advanced topic for this
video so I would highly recommend you to
go and read more about it and if you
haven't accessed the complete playlist
for our JavaScript interview series you
can go to YouTube dot com slash roadside
coder and here inside the playlists
you're gonna find the complete playlist
here in this playlist tab section all
right now let's move on to our next
topic which is on closures closures is
the most important topic for JavaScript
interviews and there can be literally
hundreds of questions that can be made
on it that's why after hundreds of years
of research I have curated some of the
most asked interview questions on
closure for this video ah just kidding I
haven't researched for that long but
it's gonna be good so a closure is a
function that references variables in
the outer scope from its inner scope to
understand the concept of closures you
need to know how the lexical scoping
works first so I've opened vs code over
here with basic HTML CSS and JavaScript
files so what is lexical scope so a
scope refers to the current context of
your code it can be either globally or
locally defined and with the es6 version
of JavaScript we also have the block
scope as we discussed in our let const
to video so let's see so since we have a
variable right over here this variable
this is in the global scope right but
what if we go on and create a function
over here
let's call it local
and so this right here is the local
scope
and this is the global scope but what
exactly is the lexical scope so a
lexical scope in JavaScript means that a
variable defined outside a function can
be accessible inside of another function
defined after a variable declaration but
the opposite is not true the variable
defined inside the function will not be
accessible outside that function so
let's see an example so if I console log
this name over here let's call it
username yeah so let's go on and run
this here's a browser let's go to
inspect
oops we are not calling this function
anymore right now
so yeah now let's see yep you see we get
this output roadside coder over here
because the variable defined outside of
this function can be accessible inside
of this function this is called lexical
scope but what if we do this if we take
this line and put it over here
and try to take this console log outside
of this function will this still work
let's see
no this is gonna give us the error
username is not defined so we cannot
access the variables from inside of the
function we can only access the
variables that are outside of this local
scope so let's see another example over
here so we have this function subscribe
over here which we are calling after it
and we have another function display
name which we are calling inside of this
function so you see we have multiple
Scopes over here so let's call it
inner scope we'll call it inner scope
and then there is this Global scope
right so we have three Scopes over here
so what's going to happen is when we
call this subscribe function over here
it's going to initialize this function
with this name roadside coder and when
we go inside of this function this will
be still accessible inside of this
function because it's outside of this
local scope right so we will be able to
print this name so let's see
yep you see it's printed over here so
this thing exactly right here is what a
closure is the display name is called a
closure I know you might be a little
confused right now but let's go on and
understand closures in depth also if you
would like to get in-depth knowledge
about JavaScript functions you can go
and check out my previous video which
was completely on functions where we
discussed all of the interview questions
related to the functions in JavaScript
all right so let's go to the Google
and search closures
and we get this mdn docs over here and
according to this documentation a
closure is a combination of a function
bundled together with references to its
surrounding State or the lexical
environment that we just discussed in
other words a closure gives you the
access to an outer function scope from
an inner function so as we saw in this
code that this function was able to
access the variable outside of this
scope
so this is what a closure exactly is in
JavaScript closures are created every
time a function is created so you can
see right here this is the example that
we discussed so if you scroll further
down they've given us another example so
let me just copy this up and paste it
right here
so what's going on over here let's see
instead of this alert I'm just gonna put
console log over here yeah so here we
have defined this local variable name
and inside this we have this function
inner function called display name and
we are returning this display name over
here so what we're doing is we are
calling this make function over here and
we're taking whatever that it's
returning us so it is returning us this
display name so now this gives us a
function which we can call anytime we
want this is the inner function of this
make function so we can go on and call
this and it's going to execute this
function right here and it's still going
to access its outer variable of Mozilla
so if you go
to the browser and see yup you see
Mozilla is printed right here and in
some of the language you wouldn't see
this type of code working but in
JavaScript this works in JavaScript
every time we create a new function it
binds itself to its environment or its
lexical scope so it doesn't matter if
you call this one directly over here or
if you return it from this function it's
still going to have the access to its
parent scope of this or or let's say
Global scope so it's still going to have
the access to the lexical scope of its
parents so you must be thinking what's
the use of this syntax so closures makes
it possible for a function to have
private variables JavaScript closure is
used to control what is and isn't in the
scope of a particular function along
with which variables are shared between
sibling functions in the same containing
scope so if I create another function
right here with some another name and
return that one as well so that will
also have the access to the scope of
this function so actually we will
discuss all of these questions and
Concepts as we move forward in this
video I just want to make sure that your
Basics are cleared at this moment first
so we're gonna start one by one also if
you want to call this function display
name we can also do this so let me
remove this up
we're calling this function and inside
this since this is this returns us
another function we can do this right
over here so this returns us the display
name and then we are calling the display
name right over here just like that so
actually we can pass anything inside of
here as well so let's see first this
works or not Yep this works as expected
so let me pass number five over here and
let's receive num
and I'm gonna print num
so yep you see number five is also
printed over here so this just works
just like a normal function but we have
much more power because of this
JavaScript closures on our scope okay so
that were the basics of closures but you
might have heard of this term called
closure scope chain let's see let's go
to the documentation again
and see what this thing is
so right here so according to this every
closure has three Scopes as we already
discussed a local scope that is
this one
the outer function scope that is this
one the outer function scope and then
the global scope so it has three Scopes
right here so a lot of people think that
okay this function will only have the
access to its outer scope and not the
scope of the parent what scope chain
means is is it's going to have the
access to its outer scope as well and
the scope of its parent so if I go on
and say where user name
and give it a value
and use this
right over here then you're gonna see
we still get the output because it has
the access to all of the Scopes of its
parent scope and the scope of its
parents parent so this is what a scope
chain is let's see what example they
have given us to explain it so as you
can see right here they have given us
this example with a lot of local Scopes
in here so let's paste it
okay so as you can see we have this
function here and then we have another
function nested then we have another
function nested and we have this sum at
the top
so we're calling this sum with one right
so it's going to give this a 1 and then
another inside of this we have another
function written okay so this will
return B now we're supposed to call B
over here so then we are calling B with
this parenthesis and we're supplying the
value of 2 to B also sorry the name of
function is not B the name of parameter
is B the function is an anonymous
function right so after that it's
returning us another anonymous function
this will be returned over here so now
we're gonna call it again with value
three so it's gonna have three and so on
it's gonna return another function so
we're calling it with this function 4
and now notice what happens
inside of it we're returning a b c d e
so this function right here will have
the access to all of the Scopes outside
of it so a scope where we have C value B
value a value and the global scope where
we have e value so it's going to be able
to access all of them and it's going to
log us 20. so let's find out
yep just like that so this is what a
closure scope chain is all about now
they've given a bunch of more examples I
would highly recommend you to go and
read more about closure and closure
scope chain from this documentation it's
gonna really help you become good in
this topic okay so let's go on and
discuss some of the most asked interview
questions on closures we're gonna start
from the very Basics and go to the
advanced level questions so as you can
see right here we're given a variable
let count equals zero and after that we
have an iffy over here so if you don't
know about what an F is you can go and
watch our previous video on functions
there I've explained what any phase and
right so we have a function over here
called print count and so this we have
this conditional and we're supposed to
tell that what this will console log and
what this will console log so okay we
have count equals zero so obviously it's
gonna take count equals 0 inside this
function as we learned up until this
video because of its lexical environment
or lexical scope but we have a problem
over here we have another count equals 1
over here well this is confusing what
will we print inside of this count then
will we print count equals 1 or count
equals zero okay so let's see so this is
checking if count is equals to zero
which yep it's at this point it is zero
so we're gonna go inside of this then
we're saying that let count equals one
now this concept right here this is
called
shadowing
and I've explained this concept in our
where let const video that this is a
block scope right here and this variable
is going to Shadow this variable from
outside so this is going to overlap the
value of count with one and it's going
to print 1 over here but outside of this
keep in mind this is inside of this
block only it's not going to affect the
environment outside of it so outside of
it count is still zero so count
is still 0 at this point so this will
print 0 it will not be affected by this
let count equals one so let's see the
output
yep you see first one gave us one and
the other one gave us zero so
interviewers give us questions like this
to understand if the candidate is aware
of Concepts like block scope or
shadowing or not okay so the next
question is to write a function that
would allow you to do this
okay so what's going on over here we are
calling this create base function with
certain value and it is returning us a
closure called add six and then we are
calling this add six closure and
whichever value that we pass inside of
it it returns Us by adding the value
that was written over here so if we did
10 so 10 plus 6 16 21 plus 6 27 okay so
how are we going to do that what we
learned up until now this is obviously
going to be a closure which will be
returned from this create base function
so let's create a this create base
function first
so create base and it's going to take a
number
cool
now from inside of this we are supposed
to return a function so let's return a
function which I'm going to keep as
Anonymous function and this I'm gonna
give
let's say inner num
and so inside this what we're supposed
to do we're supposed to add inner num to
this num so we're gonna return
in a num plus num and obviously since
this is a closure so num will be
accessible inside this function
so let's see if this works or not oh I
think I should console log this
or maybe I think I should console log
this
and put this inside of here
yep
let's see
okay we got this output 16 and 27. so
what's happening over here is we have
taken this create base as six and we
have created a local scope for both of
these function calls so we just have to
do this once and this will be
initialized with a scope where num is
six now doesn't matter what we pass
inside of over here if we pass 15 over
here it's still going to add 6 to it
just like that so what's happening over
here is you can create a closure to keep
the value passed to a function create
base even after the inner function is
returned so if we don't want this value
to change then we can create a closure
where this value is always 6 we just
have to pass it once and it's going to
access the value as only 6. so this is
also one of the use case of closures
which makes it so powerful okay so this
question right here is kind of similar
to the previous question but it's a
little add-on to that how can we use
closures to optimize the time of our
code so interviewer has given us this
find function when we call this find
function right here by the way just
ignore this console.time for now I've
just added this to measure how much time
does this function call takes okay so
first we are calling this find function
with this six value okay so it takes the
six value right here and it has the
empty array and what it's doing over
here we we have a really long Loop which
runs 1 million times and what it's doing
over is it's assigning the value of I
into I to each of the index of this
array okay that's fine so this is being
done to make this Loop really slow and
then we are console logging the index
whatever index that we provide so if we
have provided the six index so we're
just supposed to print that okay so
let's save this and check this out okay
so you can see right here it gives us
this output but it's taking this six
millisecond right here and the other
call takes 12 milliseconds if we put
even higher number over here let's say
uh 50 so it's taking 135 millisecond
right here sorry I said 6 earlier but
it's 67 milliseconds for the this one
and this is 135 milliseconds for this
one so how can we optimize this by using
closures so just like what we did in our
previous since we are not touching this
value anytime right we this value is the
same for each and every time we call
this function so let's create a function
right here
an anonymous function
which will take this console log
inside of it instead of passing this
index over there we're going to pass
this index over here so let's do this
let's create const closure
which will have this find right here
so we have just created a inner function
closure for us so that this Remains the
Same for every time we call this closure
right here so now I'm going to replace
this with this closure and this is 50
right here so I'm gonna put 50 so we can
recognize this
okay so let's see what has changed okay
there's a huge change right here so for
six I think it was 67 earlier but now
it's 0.25 milliseconds there's a huge
time optimization of this code and for
50 it was I think 100 135 something but
now it's 0.025 so you see how closure
has helped us in optimizing the time for
our code so this is the reason why
closure is such an important topic and
such a favorite topic of interviewers
okay so let's move on to our fourth
question which is on block scope and set
timeout with closures so this question
is really really important and this
question is asked in a lot of companies
I've already discussed this question in
my unacademy interview experience video
so I'm gonna go on and play that clip
for you right here so the interviewer
provided me with this code snippet and
obviously we're gonna run this over here
so he asked me what is going to be the
output for this
so let's think about it most people will
think that since we are console logging
over here we are running a loop over
here for Loop and we are console logging
each of these values inside of over here
after one second each so most people
will think that the output is going to
be this 0 1
two
is it let's find out
it is three three times let's refresh
the page
so three three and three after one
second each so why is this happening
this is because of where so what where
does is we just discussed in our
previous question so where doesn't have
a block scope where has a function
scoped so what's happening over here is
first time this runs whereas value is
zero but this is not going to be printed
right away because set timeout only runs
after the complete code has ran
successfully right so this is not going
to run so we have a reference to that I
variable in our memory so we have a
reference over here let's say
okay then again the I is 1 then we again
have a reference to the I variable
just like that and then I is 2 then we
again have a reference to I variable and
then the third time the value of I is 3
but if we obviously we won't go inside
of over here since it says that I has to
be less than 3 so we're not going to run
inside of it we come out of this Loop
and then set timeout has finished its
time and now our JS engine is going to
print all of these values so last time
the JS engine encountered the value of I
it was 3. now here JS engine is
referring to the current value of I so
the current value of I was 3 so it's
going to print 3 3 and 3. just like that
now what's the solution for this
you may have guessed it right the
solution for this is using let instead
of where
let's see the output 0 1 2 yes so what's
happening over here is let is block
scoped so first of all let's value was
zero so it has the completely different
scope so in this scope the value of I
was 0. so it's going to print it later
on
then again
the second value of I was 1. so again
after the complete code has ran
successfully it's going to look into the
scope of that I variable and when it
looks into all the three Scopes it's
going to find 0 1 and 2. so this is the
logic behind this question
so actually this was the follow-up
question that the interviewer asked I
just explained it to you in one go so
these were two different questions that
the interviewer asked interview asked
first to tell him the output of the
First with where and then he asked me
how we can print zero one two so then I
went on and explained him with let
so this was the question but few of the
interviewers extend this question even
more they're gonna say you're not
allowed to use let you're gonna have to
use where instead of let and you have to
print 0 1 2 you have to give this output
how are we gonna do that so this is a
task for you all I'm gonna give you a
small hint it's going to use closures
all right pause if you're not yet
following me on Twitter go to
twitter.com
or click the link in the description
down below and hit that follow button
right now I'm waiting for you
I'm still waiting
okay fine let's continue with the video
okay so in the end of that clip I asked
you a question that how will you do this
just by using where
how will you print 0 1 2 3 by using
where only instead of lit so how will
you do that you're gonna use closures so
we're gonna create a closure over here
let's say inner
and it's going to take I as a local
variable
and I'm going to put all of this inside
of this closure
and we will call this inner closure and
pass the I to it so what's going to
happen is every time this I is passed to
this function it is not going to
reference just like we discussed it's
not going to reference that particular
memory value it's going to create a
whole different memory space for this
function right here for every time this
Loop runs so we're passing I over here
and now I will be a local variable
inside of this function rather than
taking it from our outer scope so let's
run this and yep you can see we get this
output 0 1 2. awesome so the next
question is how would you use a closure
to create a private counter so what is a
private counter let me show you
so if you create a function right here
called counter and we don't take
anything inside of it and we have a
variable counter equals zero so I've put
underscore over here because this is a
convention when we create private
variables we put underscore before that
you don't have to follow this but it's a
good practice so how can we create a
private counter so we already know that
we can't access this variable outside of
this function right so how are we going
to update it so I'm going to create a
bunch of functions inside of it first
one will be the add
which takes an increment variable by how
much value is this going to be
incremented so this is going to return
okay
increment so it's going to add this
increment to this counter way and you
know what we don't need this return
statement my bad so we're just going to
do this it's just going to add this
increment to counter
cool then we'll have another function
which will retrieve the value of counter
it's going to say return
counter
counter equals
and I'm gonna provide the counter just
like that now we're going to return both
of these functions so
I'm going to return
add
retrieve
just like that cool so let's go on and
initialize this counter right here so
I'm gonna say
const C equals counter
so this has created a new counter a
private counter so what we can do is we
can say C dot add and we can provide it
value let's say five so it's going to
add 5 to that counter and let's say if
we provide it value let's say 10 so
after this the counter should be at 15
right so let's go on and call retrieve
and check
so let's see in our browser
um okay I think oh yeah we're supposed
to console log this
since it's returning the value
all right so counter equals 15. so this
is what a private counter is we are not
directly manipulating the counter we are
using these functions right here to
manipulate the value of this private
variable or a private or the private
counter now there's a similar concept
which relates to this one which is
called a module pattern which we're
going to discuss in our next question so
interior can ask you this question that
what is a module pattern so a module
pattern looks something like this
so we have a if we write here and we
have a private function inside of it and
we have a public function which we are
returning to the user so user can make
use of this public function and this
public function we can write a code
inside of it which can call this private
method right here or the private methods
or private variables of this module
right here so they will not be
accessible outside of this module
pattern so private functions are not
returned not returning these functions
makes them inaccessible outside of the
module namespace but our public function
can access our private functions which
makes them handy for like helper
functions for example if we are supposed
to make an API call inside of it but we
don't want the user to access it
directly so we can just use our public
method to let's say manipulate it in
some way so that it works exactly as the
developer wants it to work so in these
cases module pattern helps us a lot so
let's say if we
go on and console log
public
and we put this inside here called
private
module
Dot Public method
and we called module dot private method
so this will be called but this will
give us error so let's see Yep this is
called and this gives us
module dot private method is not a
function because it's not going to be
returned from that function cool I would
highly recommend you to go and read more
about module pattern on your own because
this can be a really important question
and sometimes it's also asked in junior
interviews but mostly in the senior
developer interviews okay so next
question is that interview provided us
this function like the video
like the video and instead of it we have
this Variable View so view is defined
outside we have declared view variable
outside and we are initializing it
inside of our function and then we are
console logging it
so the question is to make this run only
once so if we call this function and
again and again you're gonna see that we
get this output again and again so what
can we do to make this run only once so
obviously we're gonna make use of
closures so we're going to create a
local variable inside of it
let's let called it's going to be 0 by
default and inside this I'm going to
create a new function I'm going to
return a new function
it's going to be an anonymous function
and inside of this I'm going to check if
called is equals to zero
then
you know what I'm going to say if called
is more than zero then obviously this is
already called so I'm gonna console log
already
subscribe
to
roadside coder and I hope you are also
subscribed to roadside coder
otherwise else if this is not more than
0 then we're gonna take this code and
put it right over here and after this is
console logged I'm gonna say called plus
plus so that called is not 0 anymore and
then we will print already subscribe to
roadside coder so I think this should
work first time they should print
subscribe to roadside coder and then
after that it should print already
subscribed let's see oops my bad I need
to call it first so I'm gonna say let
I'm just gonna remove this for now I'm
going to say is Subs
subscribed
and it's gonna take
like the video
and now we can call this so by doing
this what we did is we created a local
scope with let called equal zero and
every time we call this it's gonna
reference to the same called variable so
let's call it bunch of times and let's
see
so the first time it printed subscribe
to roadside coder and after that it
printed already subscribed to roadside
coder yeah so this is what we exactly
wanted which will make this run only
once now this is not the proper
implementation of this once but you can
use it if the interviewer asks you to do
something like this but if interviewer
asks you to create a more generic
function then how are you going to do
that let's see so actually there's a
library called Low Dash which already
has an implementation of this once
function so I'm gonna go on and create
the polyfill for this once function
right here okay so let's create a more
of a generic function so I'm gonna
create a function with the name of once
and it's going to take two things it's
going to take a function and it's going
to take a context uh local context if
there's any context there now inside
this we're going to create a local
variable called ran and I'm just going
to clear it like that which will
determine if this function has been ran
once or not and after that I'm going to
create a closure which is going to be
anonymous function and start this I'm
gonna check if there's something inside
of the function
then go inside of it
and ran will be function dot apply and
I'm going to provide the context
if the context is provided otherwise I'm
just gonna provide the this that is
whatever the context of this function is
I'm just gonna point to that one by
using this don't worry as I've already
mentioned that I'm going to bring a
complete video on this implicit and
explicit binding which will cover this
this variable and call apply bind all of
these Concepts so don't worry that video
is coming very soon so all this apply
does is all you need to understand for
now that it's giving our function a new
context and the arguments if any so I'm
going to pass all of the arguments and
as you know this arguments will be an
array so I would highly recommend you to
go and read about this apply function if
you don't understand how this works
because that will be a little out of
scope for this video so all it's doing
over here is it's providing it a new
context and a bunch of arguments let's
say if we have one comma two comma 3
it's going to provide it just like that
now after this is after this this runs
it's gonna provide the output to this
Rand variable and I'm gonna put the
function to null so that we can not call
it again
and after that we're gonna return null
oops return ran
just like that and this is our once
function right here don't worry I'm
gonna run this and again explain you how
this exactly works so let's say I have
variable hello which is a function
which console logs hello
so how are we supposed to run this only
once so if I print this
multiple times
you're gonna see that it runs multiple
times okay but when we wrap this
inside of this once function that we
have created right here then you're
going to see that it runs only once it's
not gonna run again and again it doesn't
matter how many times you call it so
what's happening over here is
it takes this function over here okay
cool now inside of this we have a
closure which will be returned inside of
this variable the reason how we are able
to call this and then we're checking it
if the function has some value yes it
has this value then we are running this
function and after we run this it's
going to have the result inside this ran
variable and function will be null so
that we can't run this again and then we
simply return the output of this
function but what if we had some very
some arguments so let's say if I pass
one comma 2
so let's take a comma B right here and
I'm gonna print
a comma p
and check this yep you see it's gonna
run with the provided arguments because
we are providing the arguments right
here so this is how one's function is
supposed to work
now for our next question we have to
create the polyfill of this memoise so
what is memoise so this question was
also asked to me during one of my
previous interviews this question was
asked to me during my cast 24 interview
which I've already discussed in that
video so I'm gonna show you that clip
right here the next question was on
implementing a caching or a memoise
function in JavaScript so for example if
you are given with this function which
has some expensive calculation inside of
it which when executed every time takes
a decent amount of time to run so if I
go on and run this
so I'm going to use console.time to
measure how much time did this took to
run
and I'm gonna run it twice actually with
the same parameters okay so if I go to
console you're gonna see first time it
took 40 milliseconds and second time is
also to second time it was 42
milliseconds so how do we minimize this
time calculation if the parameters of
the function are same we need to Cache
the the result of the previous function
somewhere right so that is what we are
going to implement so let's say I'm
gonna go over here at the top and I'm
gonna have function
which I'm gonna say my memoize and it's
going to take a function which we are
supposed to memorize and we're going to
take a context and you know what let me
remove this context for now I'm gonna
show you how we're gonna use that later
so right now we're just going to take a
function and this memoise and first of
all let's create a variable for storing
our results so const
equals an empty object so this will be
the place where the result for our
previously executed function will store
or the cache for our function right
then after this I'm gonna return a
function
and inside of this I'm gonna take the
arguments from the user after making
this a memoized functions now first of
all I'm gonna convert all of these
arguments that we get from this function
into a string so I'm going to say where
RX cache equals Json Dot stringify and
inside of this I'm going to provide the
arcs so what's going to happen is this
args cache will contain all of these
arguments now we're going to take this
args cache and check if we already got
these arguments in our cash or not and
if we already got a result for all of
these arguments so I'm gonna go down and
say if I'm going to check inside the
rest so res
RX cache so if
we don't have these arguments inside of
our object then we're gonna calculate
the result for that function otherwise
we're just gonna return
what we already have so return
this thing
just like this so we're gonna return all
of the result for that object so for
example if we are providing five and six
so our result object will look like this
so let's say a result of 30 right so
this is how our address object will look
like and if it finds out that it already
has those parameters so it's just gonna
return us this value so let me write the
logic for that
so inside of over here I'm gonna say I'm
just gonna add that inside of our res
object so rest
arcs cash
will contain the result of the logic for
that function so function dot call
and now over here we are going to use
that context so if we are sending any
context
I'm just gonna provide it so obviously
this context is going to be optional so
that's why I'm Gonna Save this context
doesn't exist just use the current
context and obviously we are going to
use this arguments that are being sent
to us so I'm just gonna spread all of
these arcs as well over here
cool so I think this looks good to me
um let's go on and use this so again I'm
gonna show you previously it gave us
this result both of these times but now
if I go on and memorize this function so
what I'm going to do I'm gonna Supply
this function
I know what first of all let me change
the name of this function I don't think
this fits the appropriate so this should
be clumsy
product that fits better
yeah so after this I'm gonna say const
okay
and I'm gonna wrap that function so I'm
just going to take this my memoise and
wrap this clumsy product
just like this
and now since it's going to return us
with a function as you saw over here
return this function so we are going to
get a function inside of this over here
so I'm just going to replace this clumsy
product with our newly memorized clumsy
product so now let's find out if it
worked or not
yup awesome so you see in the first call
it gave us 49 millisecond and in the
second call it was 0.08 milliseconds
oops my bad I made a mistake over here
so the else is not going to be over here
so this is just going to be returned so
it's just going to check see this is an
optional condition over here it's gonna
check if it's no if it doesn't exist
inside of this array then just add it to
our result and then return it
otherwise if it is inside of our result
object then just return it directly
so now you're gonna see
yep now we get both of these result over
here awesome so this is how you go on
and Implement a caching or a
memorization function in JavaScript so
this is a really important interview
question all right so our next question
which can also be very frequently Asked
is the difference between closure and
scope so whenever you create a function
within another function then the inner
function is the closure this closure is
usually returned so we can use the outer
functions variable at a later time so
this is what a closure is whereas a
scope in JavaScript defines what
variable you have access to there are
two kinds of a scope as we already
discussed Global scope and local scope
and in case of closures there are Global
scope outer scope and local scope so you
can give this answer in your interviews
and that should be good enough and these
were all of the interview questions
related to the closure all right now
let's move on to our next topic which is
going to be on currying and this is a
very important section of this video
because you need to give me your full
attention to understand this topic
because some people might find this
topping a little bit overwhelming but
this is very important for our
JavaScript interviews while preparing
for this video a lot of interviewers
told me that carrying is the topic whose
questions are the one a lot of
candidates fail to answer just because
they don't know how it exactly works or
don't have their Basics right so what is
this carrying anyway carrying is a
function that takes one argument at a
time and returns a new function
expecting the next argument it is a
conversion of functions from callable as
this into callable as this
and curried functions are constructed by
chaining closures by immediately
returning their inner function
simultaneously so if you haven't watched
the last video of this series which was
on closures you can watch that video by
clicking on link in the description or I
button above now don't worry if you're
unable to understand what I just
explained by the end of this video
you'll be able to answer most of the
questions that can be formed on currying
so let's understand it with an example
okay so I've opened vs code over here
with basic HTML CSS and JavaScript files
and let's understand currying with this
simple example so as I mentioned we have
a function f with params a comma B and
it prints
a comma B so when we convert this type
of normal function into this type of
format this is called carrying so let's
see how we can do that so instead of
writing this we can write a function
f with param a and as I mentioned in
carrying a function takes one argument
at a time and returns a new function
expecting the next argument so we're
gonna return a new function
we're gonna keep it as Anonymous
function
with no name and with the B parameter
and inside of this we're just gonna
simply console log
a comma B just like before okay let's
try to run this
I'm gonna console log function with
value 5. let's see what do we get when
we run this much of the code so let me
run this by opening with live server
there we go let's go to the console
and in the console you can see we get
another function over here so how do we
run this we can
go over here and since this is returning
us a function what we can do is we can
call it just like this with something
else so let's say if I enter 6 over here
let's see what do we get but you know
what instead of this I'm just gonna say
return
with a and
B
just like that
so and without this
we get this function returned to us so
this is how occurring works this is how
we convert a normal function into a
function which is carried there can be a
lot of levels to this we can have more
parenthesis over here just like this so
it depends on how deep the carrying is
and we're going to discuss all the types
of question that interviewers can ask
you during the interview process
now there's an interview question where
interviewer can ask you why do we use
currying so there can be a lot of answer
to this question to avoid passing the
same variable again and again to create
higher order functions to make your
function pure and less prone to errors
so actually this is more of a theory
question so instead of making this video
too long I've written a Blog on currying
which you can check out by clicking the
link in the description below and follow
along with this video in that blog I've
included a lot of theory questions and
all of the interview questions that I'm
going to discuss in this video as we
move along so definitely go and check
out that blog with link in the
description below alright so let's get
down to our first question which is how
will you implement this sum function
like this and what this function should
do is this function should sum all of
the parameters that are provided to this
parenthesis so this is actually very
similar to the example that I discussed
few minutes ago so I will highly
recommend you to go and try this
question yourself first so pause the
video right now and try this question
yourself and then continue with this
video
so I hope you were able to solve this
question let's go and understand how we
can do this so as I explained to you we
have a function first
let's go from scratch so how I would
explain this question to the interviewer
is so I'll go and explain by creating a
normal function first sum with three
parameters let's say a b and c and
return
a plus b plus C just like that and if
you go and console log this
sum let's say 2 comma 6 comma 1
so we'll obviously get the output nine
but how do we implement it
just like this so right below this
actually I'm going to comment it out
first yeah below this I'm going to
create another function sum which takes
a and insert this as we already
discussed incurring a function takes one
argument at a time and returns a new
function expecting the next argument
we're going to create a new function
which will give us another argument
so I'm gonna create a function an
anonymous function with parameter of B
and after that I'm gonna create since we
have another parameter over here another
parenthesis so I'm gonna return
another function with C whoops C and
inside of this finally we can return our
answer
which is going to be a plus b plus c
now if we go on and run this
sum
a I mean 2
and then six and then
one
and go and check it out
yep we got the same output now if you
want to explain this in much more in
depth to the interviewer you can explain
this just the way I explained you so you
can
start by one parameter you can say that
if we provide it two then it's going to
return us a function which is going to
expect another parameter B and when we
provide it B which let's say we provide
six
that's going to expect another parameter
which is C so we're gonna provide it the
third parameter as well and then we are
going to get the final answer which is
going to be a plus b plus c
all right so our next question is this
we need to create a function called
evaluate and we provide it a parameter
of some multiply divide or
subtract so we can provide this either
of these operations and after that we're
going to provide it to parameters over
here which are going to give us the
result according to this so if this is
some this is going to add this if this
multiplier this is going to multiply
this and so on so we're going to go on
and create a function over here called
evaluate
and first thing that is going to be
taking is this type of operation so I'm
going to give this operation parameter
answer this
is obviously going to return another
function because it because it is
expecting another argument so we're
going to provide it
we're going to return another function
which is going to be anonymous function
and I'm going to give this let's say a
and inside this it's going to be
expecting another parameter so I'm gonna
return another function
which is going to have a parameter B and
now insert this with respect to this
operation we're going to give the output
so I'm going to check if operation
is equals to sum then return a plus b
and so on so let me write this quickly
just like that otherwise let's return if
the none of the operations are there
then I'm just going to return invalid
operation
cool all right let's try to run this so
I'm gonna say evaluate and I'm gonna
write sum over here and I'm going to
provide this
let's say 4 and 2. let's see what do we
get
oh I need to console log this
all right we got six over here let's see
we will try to give this multiply
okay we got multiply okay so so you can
write this actually in some other way as
well so I'm gonna create a const uh
mul
and I'm gonna provide this evaluate
multiply so this is one of the use cases
of Curry since we have provided this
multiply over here this will always
perform multiply so you can reuse this n
number of times so if I go on Console
log mer and mult will all obviously will
have this function return to it so we
can say
three
five which should give us 15
and we can reuse it again
let's say 2 and 6 which should give us
12 so we should have 15 and 12 as an
output yep just like that so you see
this is one of the use cases of currying
that we initialized our function once
with multiply or whatever that we wanted
to so we we're not initializing it again
and again by providing multiply every
time we call this so we just provided it
and initialized it once and now we can
use this mult function over here to
multiply these numbers again and again
so during the interview you can explain
all of these things to the interviewer
and the interviewer will really be
impressed now our next question is on
infinite carrying so what is infinite
carrying so interview will ask us to
write a function which we can call just
like this with n number of parameters so
if you have function like this sum and
we can say 1
1 and 2 so this should give us three but
we can also call this function like this
we can add a 4 5 or we can add n number
of parameters after this
and this should be flexible according to
the number of parameters and should give
us the answer accordingly which in this
case is going to be 12. so how do we do
this so this question was actually asked
to me during my cast 24 interview and
I've already discussed in this class 24
interview experience video so I'm going
to go on and play that clip right here
so the interviewer provided me with this
code snippet and he asked me to
implement this add function so let's see
how we can Implement that so we create a
function called add and it takes a
parameter let's say a
okay so we have a bunch of parameters
over here so it's obviously going to
return a function then we are going to
call that function with another
parameter with another parameter so it
can go infinite right it's not it's just
not that we have to implement it till
five two four five and then that's it
because that will be easy right so if I
so let me remove this complexity for now
and I'm just going to implement with
just two parameters so this function a
and it's obviously going to return a
function so I'm going to say return
function B let's say
or let's say Anonymous function
and it's going to take B and then inside
of it I'm just gonna return another
function
which will have let's say a plus b
okay
right so now if we go on and execute
this you're gonna see we get the output
S7
yep just like that but we don't want
that we don't want this much complexity
right so we want to create we want to
write a code which works infinitely so
if I let's say go on and add four and
eight over here this should adapt to
that code so what I'm going to do I'm
gonna remove this inner function and I'm
gonna say we have two of these but then
I'm gonna check if we have any more
params or not so I'll check if
B has a param then just returned
this add again I'm just going to provide
the value of a plus b and just continue
this so a plus b
and that's it but if B doesn't have any
value inside of it that means it's
coming to an end so I'm just gonna
return
a so let me explain this again to you so
let's say we have 5 2 4 8 over here so
first of all we provided it with the 5
and it returned us a function okay so
then we again called it with 2 we called
B with the two but if it's gonna check
if 2 is there or not if there is some
value inside of b or not only then it's
going to return the addition otherwise
it's just going to return the initial 5
value the sum of those numbers up until
that point so okay so we did have 2 at
that point so we said okay if 2 is there
then return a plus b so 5 plus 2 was
returned so 5 plus 2 that is 7 went
inside of this function so now its value
is 7 over here but then again it's going
to return another function then it's
going to check if we are calling that
function as empty but no this is not
empty it has 4 inside of it so then
again it's going to check if there's
something inside of the B then return a
plus b so at this point a is value was 7
so it's gonna say 7 plus 4 that is 11.
so it's gonna pass 11 to that so this
cycle will run again and again and again
until we reach this point so up until
this point the value was 19. so then
it's gonna have a 19 value over here and
it's going to return a function again
and then it's going to check if B has
something but here B doesn't have
anything so it's not going to go inside
of it and it's just going to return a
that is 19 from here so our answer is
going to be 19. yep we got this output
over here now the next question that the
interviewer can ask you is the
difference between carrying and partial
application now what is this partial
application let's see now you may have
start to think that the number of nested
functions a curried function has depends
on the number of arguments it receives
and yes that is what makes it a curry
let's take some example so if we have a
function
sum with a and it returns another
which has B comma C and then they return
a
plus b plus c
just like that and this can be called
like this
we provided 10 and then we can call X
let me console log this
or it can be called as sum it can be
called directly as
you get what I'm trying to explain right
so it can be called in either of these
ways so you get what I'm trying to
explain right it can be called in either
of this or this way so these function
expect three arguments and has two
nested functions unlike our previous
version that expect three argument and
has three nesting functions so the first
question that we discussed in which the
sum had three nesting functions and had
three arguments so that is what our
statement was right that the number of
nested functions are carried function
has depends on the number of arguments
it received but in this case that is not
the case in this case we have three
arguments but we are only returning two
functions over here so this right here
is not carrying we just did a partial
application for this sum function what
partial application does is partial
application transform a function into
another function with small rity also if
you don't know Rarity just means the
number of operands or the arguments are
function receives so if we were to write
this same function with currying we
would have written it something like
this because in this we have three
arguments and we are returning three
functions but in this we have three
arguments but we are returning only two
function so that is the difference
between carrying and partial application
this right here is partial application
now in some cases interviewer can ask
you to explain a real world scenario for
using currying while developing our web
applications we can actually use current
to manipulate our Dom as well so let me
give you an example right here and you
can give the same example to your
interviewer as well so I'm going to go
to the HTML file and I'm going to add
another H1 tag over here called hello
piyush and here it is
now I'm going to go to our Javascript
file so right here I'm going to create a
function called update element text and
this is going to take an ID and insert
this I'm going to create another
function which will take content and
insert this I'm just gonna write
document dot query selector and I'm
going to provide this the ID
#id oops
just like that
Dot and I'm going to update the text
content to be the content provided right
over here now what we can do is we since
we have an ID over here oops I haven't
provided the ID so let me give this ID
of heading
let's take this ID
now what we can do over here is we can
just initialize this function with our
ID once and we can update the text of
our heading again and again by calling
this the function that will be returned
from this so let me show you so const
update header
and I'm gonna call update element text
and I'm going to provide this this
heading
ID now we can use this update header
again and again every time we want to
update the text inside of this heading
right over here so let me show you I'm
just gonna call
update header right here and I'm gonna
say hello
roadside coder
and let's see yep you see we have
updated it or we can write
subscribe
to roadside coder
and you see it has been updated so yeah
we can use this function again and again
in our code according to let's say the
condition if we click on a button we can
call this function again and again we
don't need to use Query selector again
and again by providing it the ID we just
need to initialize it once and we can
use it just like this so yeah you can
give this answer to your interviewer and
they will definitely be impressed and
think that you have used carrying in
your apps before now do you remember in
the beginning of this video I gave you
an example on how we can convert a
function like this into this and this is
what a curried function is so how about
we write a function called Curry which
converts this function into this
function now this is the most important
question of this video now this question
is usually asked during the senior
interviews but can sometimes be asked
during Junior interviews as well so
let's write a function called Curry
which converts a normal function into a
curried function
so I'm going to write function Curry
and this is obviously going to take a
function so I'm going to provide a
function right here and this is going to
return us a curried function which will
look something like this
so I'm gonna return curried
function
or just carry it funk so this is going
to take all of the arguments of the
function in the form of the array so
arcs right here will be the array of all
of the arguments so what we'll do over
here is I'm gonna check if
function dot length is more than equals
to RX dot length so that is what
occurring is right if the function dot
length is equals to RX dot length
because the number of argument has to be
the equals to the number of functions
written so if it's not equal then what
we'll do is this is this is actually our
base case to check if it's not then
we're going to return
func
with arcs else we will return a function
which will collect all of the next
arguments that are going to be returned
to us spreading the values of the
arguments first and then the next
arguments calling the correct Funk
recursively
so let me show you it's going to be a
little confusing but don't worry I'm
going to explain you after writing this
whole thing so let me write this out
first so return
function
with all of the next arguments and
inside of this I'm gonna call this
current funk
with arcs
and of the next arguments until this
becomes more than all of the arguments
of function length so yeah let's test
this out and I'm gonna explain to you
after that
so we have function sum over here and
insert this query function we're going
to provide this sum function right over
here and inside this total sum we will
have this current Funk now this thing
will be a carried function so I'm going
to call it just like this
so let's see we should get the output
oops I made a mistake over here so
I'm gonna check if RX dot length
is more than equals function dot length
yeah now let's see so yeah we get this
output 6. now let's understand how this
whole thing is working so we've created
a function sum over here right which
takes four arguments and it calculates
the sum for it okay then we have created
a variable total some over here and
we're passing this sum function to this
Curry implementation that we have done
right over here okay cool then we're
calling this total sum just like this
way so let's see what's happening we've
provided this one to this so obviously
when we do this this is going to return
as a function which is going to be this
carried Funk right so we have supplied
it one first of all so one will be
supplied to it then it goes inside of it
it's gonna check RX dot length so arc's
length right now is just one so let me
show you if I go on Console log and I'm
going to say arcs dot length
and I'll also do func dot length
oops
first time the number of arguments were
one and
length of the function was 4 that is
these four functions second time the
length of argument was 2 then 3 then 4
and the moment the number of argument
exceeded it's gonna call this function
right over here with all of the
arguments so I'm going to explain you as
we move along so let's do this step by
step so I'm going to comment this line
now so yeah first time we have called it
with this one so it's going to check RX
dot length so our DOT length right now
is one obviously it's not more than the
function dot lens so it's not going to
go inside of it it's going to go over
here now this is going to call this
curried funk over here recursively so
what this will do is this will return us
a function expecting next arguments so
if I remove this for now
and run this you're gonna see that it
returns us another function which is
expecting the next arguments because
obviously the criteria for this is not
satisfied carrying means the number of
arguments should be equal to number of
functions and the number of function has
to be 4 since the number of arguments
are 4 the number of functions are also
supposed to be 4 only then this is going
to run so
if we provide it another
let's say six
then again it's going to expect the next
argument because then it's gonna go over
here with 6 and now arcs dot length is
2. so over here it's going to check
args.land 2 is not more than
function.length okay so it's not going
to go over here it's going to come again
over here so in the case of third
argument as well it's going to again
expect
you to supply the next functions
but the moment we Supply it with the
fourth arguments what it's going to do
it's going to take all of these and
provide it to this sum function that is
this function right over here and when
we run this
you're gonna see we have successfully
calculated the sum for all four of these
now you can write any function over here
and this is going to make it a carried
function this is how much powerful this
function is now I know this is a little
bit confusing to you but try to rewind
the video and re-watch my explanation
that I did just now you'll be able to
understand it properly so here that was
carrying in JavaScript and if you like
this video give this video a huge fat
Thumbs Up And subscribe to the channel
for more such awesome interview videos